safe and effective covid19 vaccine are
arriving
at sites across america
vaccinations begin today as soon as
healthcare workers are ready to start
providing them
america is one of the very first
countries to roll out a safe and
effective vaccine for this virus and
america has played a greater role than
any other in getting the world to this
point
president trump's operation warp speed
has helped bring us a medical miracle
substantial quantities of a safe and
effective vaccine within a year after
the virus was first known to the world
i want to thank the president for his
bold vision for his unwavering support
of operation warp speed and for bringing
together
all of america hhs the military the
private sector and the states to make
this happen
this week everyone's work starts to pay
off
this weekend shipment of vaccines is 2.9
million doses enough to vaccinate 2.9
million people with 2.9 million doses
held back
and sent in 21 days for people to
receive their second dose
each friday from here on out we will
announce new weekly allocations of
vaccine it's likely that another vaccine
may be authorized in the coming days if
it meets fda's rigorous standards
pending the successful authorization of
other vaccine options
we have enough vaccines already
purchased to ensure we can meet our goal
of vaccinating every american who wants
it by the end of the second quarter of
2021
we continue to negotiate for and
purchase more doses too
including the announcement of another
100 million doses of moderna
to be delivered in the second quarter of
2021.
states and other jurisdictions have
decided who will be vaccinated in the
early stages
drawing on their own best judgment their
own situation and the recommendations of
experts
these jurisdictions will generally be
using these first doses to immunize
front-line health care workers along
with
residents of long-term care facilities
like nursing homes and assisted living
facilities
today the cdc distributed another 140
million dollars in funding to states to
continue planning efforts around
allocation operation warp speed is
taking care of the cost of the vaccines
themselves
the ancillary supplies like needles and
syringes
and the cost of distributing the
vaccines to jurisdictions
while health care payers are handling
administration costs so no american
faces an out-of-pocket expense for this
vaccine
these jurisdictions have given us the
locations where they want vaccines
shipped
in total 636 sites nationwide with 145
sites expected to receive vaccine today
425 tomorrow
and 66 sites on wednesday
as we speak vaccine is arriving at sites
and
in trucks and planes owned by ups and
fedex to bring these life-saving
products to the places where americans
will receive them
by wednesday vaccine will be delivered
everywhere from sites
here in washington to the shores of guam
to the northeastern corner of maine
here in washington members of our
military hhs
public health leaders and private sector
partners are running an operations
center 24 7
where many of them have been essentially
all weekend to ensure these vaccines get
where they're supposed to go
without delay americans who may be in
these early categories of
health care workers or those in
long-term care facilities
should look for information from their
state governments like their state covet
19
webpage or for for guidance about where
and when vaccinations would occur
we know americans will want to know how
quickly vaccines are being
administered and what kind of progress
we're making
we want to ensure that any picture we
give of this progress is accurate and we
plan to provide more updates in our
on our work with states to provide as
much information as possible in the
coming days and weeks
like so many americans i eagerly await
the day when i can go receive a safe and
effective vaccine and the
day when my family can do that too in
the coming weeks
i and all of our public health leaders
across the administration
will be out making a major push to
educate americans about
the incredible safety and effectiveness
of these vaccines
this fda authorized vaccine and each
vaccine fda potentially authorizes will
have been through the typical
numerous stages of safety review and
more
this vaccine has gone through clinical
trials much larger than many vaccine
trials
it's gone through the drug companies
checks it's gone through an independent
data
safety and monitoring board it's gone
through the fda's independent advisory
committee
it's been subjected to transparent
standards that the fda
has published of its requirements and
it's been authorized
by fda's career scientific experts
at 95 efficacy this vaccine is
extraordinarily effective
at protecting you from this virus
getting vaccinated will help keep you
your family and your country healthy and
safe
in the meantime and in the coming months
as our country approaches full
vaccination
we have to continue taking steps to keep
ourselves our loved ones
and our community safe wash your hands
watch your distance
wear your face coverings when you can't
watch your distance and avoiding
avoid settings where you can't do those
things or you may let your guard down
every sacrifice you make in the coming
months will help save lives and ensure
that we emerge from this pandemic
as soon as possible each vaccine
administered
in these coming days is a tribute to the
generosity and genius of this country
the achievements of every american who
made operation warp speed possible
should be a point of pride for us all
our war against the virus is not over
yet but this week we're taking a major
step toward our eventual
victory with that i'll hand things over
to dr
monsev slowly to provide an update on
development and he will then turn to
general purna who will give us a more
update
an in-depth update on vaccine
distribution
dr slavi thank you mr secretary uh hello
everybody
well just very very quickly first
acknowledge
a historical event last week with the
approval of the
pfizer vaccine i think a great
accomplishment
by science and
the investment on in basic research
a great accomplishment by academic
science by
science and development in
biotech industry in the pharmaceutical
industry
and a great public-private partnership
as as
uh enabled by uh the u.s government so
really i think great job but yesterday
was just the first step
with the pfizer vaccine approval
this week probably tomorrow the booklet
for verpack review of the modern vaccine
will be made public and many of you will
have an opportunity to
look more in depth into how
remarkably aligned with the pfizer data
the modern data are also with almost 95
percent efficacy
against disease 100 efficiency against
severe disease
and more for you to review tomorrow
that booklet and the vaccine will be
reviewed
at the verb meeting
by the fda on thursday and hopefully
as for pfizer diligently followed by
potentially an approval of the vaccine
and distribution
we have ensured
significant commitment in terms of
vaccine those availability from moderna
with
100 million in the first quarter and a
second 100 million
announced on friday in the second
quarter of 2021
we are in active discussions with pfizer
to
similarly extend the number of doses
available
for the american population
but things don't stop there you know
that we have two
other vaccines in phase three trials the
johnson and johnson janssen's vaccine a
one-shot vaccine we now
are almost at 42 000 subjects recruited
in the city
so slightly more than the cap we
announced last last
week the study will stop recruiting
later this week and given the intensity
of transmission
in the us uh and in the other countries
where the trial is being conducted we
definitely expect to have first readouts
of that trial
in in the first parts of the month of
january and
likely potentially a complete
readout of the trial towards the end of
the month
and the submission of an eua
vaccine doses from the j j vaccine
will if approved start to participate to
immunizing the u.s population
in the month of february and going
forward and because it's a one dose
vaccine
they can really scale up very quickly
the number of u.s vaccines that
would be uh uh immunized uh the
the fourth vaccine that we have in the
portfolio that's in phase
three trials is the astrazeneca uh
vaccine
you know that that vaccine has undergone
phase 3 trials
in the uk in brazil and in south africa
but
also under operation warp speed we have
conducted a clinical trial
mostly here in the us we have more than
22 000 subjects recruited in that trial
and that trial should also be completing
its
first efficacy readout somewhere in the
probably
second half of the month of january and
potentially be
ready for an eua submission uh
later in february and again
participating with vaccine doses
uh in the month of march and going
forward these are the reasons why
we feel confident provided that the
vaccines performance
remains on the path that we are on
that we will be able to have enough
vaccine doses to immunize the u.s
population
there's two points i want to say in in
conclusions one is
it's very very important now that
vaccines are approved in the u.s
that americans continue to act
in a generous way in that they would
continue to participate
in two clinical trials it is thanks to
the participation
of tens of thousands of americans in the
pfizer and the modern trials
that we are able to have these vaccines
approved today and that we are able to
assess their
efficacy and their safety and likewise
for the
yansens and for the astrazeneca trial
we have two more vaccines in the
portfolio using more classical
protein-based
vaccine platform technology please
continue to participate in the trial
these vaccines are very likely to be
as effective as the vaccines that we
know already
and as safe as those vaccines it may
very well be that participating in the
clinical trials could be the fastest way
to access vaccination you know that we
are doing the best we can in terms of
providing vaccine doses but these are
rolling
in the few millions per week
participating in a clinical trial may
allow you either immediately to have a
vaccine dose
or immediately on completion of the
trial if you were on the placebo group
to have a vaccine
injected and the second key point is
really to continue our engagement
and all experts real experts engagement
with the population to explain the data
now that the data is available in public
that demonstrate the efficacy and the
safety of these vaccines
it's very important that we increase the
number of americans that
accept to be vaccinated based on facts
and data and reality because vaccines on
a shelf
are useless and unless the majority the
large majority of us gets vaccinated
we will not be able to control this
pandemic i'll stop here and pass on to
general perna who will tell us more
about
distribution flowey thank you and of
course mr secretary thank you for
allowing me to be a part of this and
just to come off of
dr slowly's last comment on saturday i
mentioned
i was asked who was going to be the
first one to receive the vaccine
and my comment was we've had over a
hundred thousand people
participate in trials they were the
first ones to receive the vaccine they
were the heroes
to really help us get going so uh i i
would applaud them
uh to dr slavi's point continuous effort
and that will be so helpful
so uh update uh first foremost uh
pfizer vaccine uh after eua on friday
a lot of work was happening over the
weekend by thousands of people
from pfizer ups fedex and mckesson
to ensure that the vaccines were packed
uh and ready to be shipped in a very
methodical
disciplined overwatched uh
approach right our goal is every vaccine
that goes out
is safe and effective upon delivery
and we wanted to make sure that
deliveries occurred
in the places where people could receive
them
and then begin administering vaccine to
the american people
it went incredibly well as i talked to
you about a lot of detailed planning and
execution to this point
our goal is our strategy is simple
one the pfizer vaccine initial push
based on what was available we wanted to
get out to american people right away i
briefed the cadence
uh that we would uh pack on saturday
that we would relocate on sunday and we
would deliver on monday
deliveries have begun uh today as we
speak
of the 145 shipments the secretary
referenced we know that 55 have been
received
and will track the remaining 95
accordingly
as we go through the day we know that
the shipments for
tomorrow's deliveries have already been
packed
and checked and will be managing each of
those
to include wednesday's shipment now
that's the initial
636 shipments that went out for the
pfizer vaccine
we have already uh identified the
follow-on orders
for pfizer vaccine and there will be an
additional 581 shipments
that will continue on beyond wednesday
thursday friday through the weekend
in delivery to the american people the
the point being it was the initial
push that we were uh
you know fully driving execution and now
we're starting
our drum beat of continuous execution of
vaccine
as it is available it's allocated to the
states
the states tell us what location they
want it on at what quantities
we package and we deliver it is a
constant flow
of available vaccine clearly the next uh
vaccine that we're looking forward to
eua this week is the moderna vaccine
uh and in that light we know that uh
we're gonna ship
just a little bit uh short of six
million doses
out to the american people uh and we're
shipping it to 3285 locations
uh across the country it'll be a very
similar cadence
uh that was executed this week with
pfizer where we're we're hitting initial
sites on monday follow on tuesday
and wednesday and then by the end of the
week we're just in a routine
cadence of execution i cannot
tell you enough right what role
commercial industries play in this right
pfizer
eventually moderna right and the work
that they're doing to get the vaccine
prepared
for final distribution mckesson in the
distribution of all the ancillary kits
for the pfizer vaccine which included
syringes
needles alcohol wipes and dilutants
and then they will also be responsible
for kidding the vaccine
for moderna right so really a remarkable
work
and then fedex and ups i just can't say
enough
to the men and women of fedex from the
leadership
all the way down uh to the persons
moving packages
from storage capability onto trucks and
planes
and then the pilots who got it out to
where we needed it
as the secretary said there is not one
part of this country
that's not being touched today through
wednesday
everybody is receiving fair and
equitable distribution of the vaccine
and it's because of the commercial
industry and the role they're playing in
the distribution
of the vaccine we're incredibly excited
about the strategy
we are continuing to provide states with
future forecasts
so that they can continue to plan our
forecasts
go from next week through the following
six weeks
for planning as i said we will
only release vaccine once the fda has
approved it
so forecasting helps for planning but
execution
is only based on approval and then we
share
those allocations with the states for
their planning
on a weekly basis again to reinforce
it is not a one and done delivery it is
a consistent
flow of ordering preparation
and delivery so vaccine con continues
it rolls out as vaccines are available
and more and more people get access to
the vaccine
every day mr secretary thank you general
we'll open for questions now
so thank you all operator um we're ready
for questions a friendly reminder that
when asking a question please state your
name in publication and please keep your
questions
as short as possible so that we can get
to as many questions as possible
thank you our first question comes from
angelica lovito with bloomberg news
your line is open
sorry can you hear me now yes yes okay
thank you
um so when will vaccination of long-term
care facilities begin and if not until
the 21st
why wait a week to start those
vaccinations
generally yes please so thank you so
uh of course we're working through the
state's plans
right and the the guidance that was put
out was
long-term uh healthcare facilities
nursing homes as one
uh priority but as well as the first
line medical
personnel who were out there so
allocations for vaccines went out to the
states
to the locations that they directed and
they are identifying
uh in those populations who is first
here's what we do know
we know that uh several states are
already going to establish or have
already established
and then going into long-term health
care facilities they'll go in there this
week
we know that the cdc in collaboration
with cvs
walgreens and the states created
a very elaborate campaign strategy for
execution into the long-term health care
facilities this week we are doing
um a scaling start into execution
four states are ready to go in
partnership with
cvs and walgreens to start scaling
the vaccine into those facilities we
know
on monday a week from today over 1100
long-term healthcare facilities in
nursing homes will also begin
vaccination
so very incredibly difficult
plan as we work to touch over 70
000 long-term health care facilities and
nursing homes
collaborated and prioritize as the
states want
many tasks have to be achieved before
you can actually walk into the door you
have to work through
make sure there's locations in the
facilities to do it
you have to make sure that all the
patients have a signed consent
which means sometimes you have to reach
out to several layers of family
to to get the final approval we have to
ensure that we have the right number of
vaccine
available to go into each of the
facilities so we're not going back and
forth
we have to ensure that the persons not
only
the elderly but the staff can be
inoculated at the same time
so we close the bubble uh on each
facility so
very detailed plan very extensive
requirement of over 70
000 uh states are already executing are
going to execute this week
and we are uh executing uh the scaled
scale start with cvs and walgreen this
week
the bluff is if they want to do we can
figure out how to get it done
but we are ready to really take a good
hard right approach uh to executing and
taking care of these great americans
uh that are in the elderly category and
uh and and just uh one extra
clarification there
uh you had mentioned the the december
21st uh just by way of background
the the cdc and working with cvs and
walgreens and mha
had in those discussions received
feedback that
remember the nursing homes had until i
think december 7th
to make their final election on
contracting with walgreens or cvs or mha
for these distribution programs and then
they had to scale
and so they asked us to be sure to give
them or in those discussions came about
to give them headroom
to be able to just get the logistics and
operations established
but there's no prohibition on
distributing and vaccinating sooner in
fact we encourage it sooner if
walgreens cvs mha are ready to go faster
and as the general said
we expect to see vaccinations in nursing
homes this week
and literally by next week
these pharmacy chains should have the
ability
to execute vaccination programs daily
in thousands of long-term care and
assisted living
facilities and progress quite rapidly
thank you
next question please thank you our next
question comes from evan brown with fox
news
uh good morning thank you all for uh
doing the call today i think this
question
might be best for the general but anyone
can answer it um
was mentioned earlier in the call that
uh there could be hiccups in
distribution because nothing is ever
perfect
um what would some of those hiccups
actually be that you might have
anticipated and what uh
what would be the remedy for those and
and how
how intense would those hiccups be so
uh i think that uh we've worked through
many many situations and i'll give you a
couple here in a moment
uh but they can be everything from as
small as uh the addresses that were sent
in weren't specified correctly i'll give
you an example
uh you know for uh collins
right the address that we double checked
i have people working on it because this
was a
situation identified had ft collins
versus f-o-r-t the system is so delicate
that you know it needed
the exact uh clarity there was two
spaces
uh in another uh state i forget which
one
major city instead of saying the part of
the city
and then the second part of the city
there was two spaces which the machine
couldn't uh identify so that is one
we've we've been identified we're
working through it we know we set up
teams to manage that so that's way over
on the left
way over on the right could be uh
anything as
you know catastrophic as an accident on
the highway
uh with a truck uh or on you know if you
know god forbid a plane
uh etc so all the way on the right then
in the middle
we have things like i know you've seen
the weather report there's
you know there's a storm that's coming
into the northeast
uh corner here on wednesday thursday and
friday there's a major storm in the
northwest
that's coming in tuesday wednesday and
thursday uh and so anything from
you know weather that could help could
be a problem
uh the other thing that we're working on
and it's a constant
the reason why we develop the strategy
of the initial pushes
and then the continuous drum beat is so
that we have the right people
at the right places doing the right work
you
need the dedicated workforce preparing
the boxes that know
how to do it right this is the most
valuable asset we have right now
and we don't want uh people overtired
we don't want new people coming in we
want the right people doing the right
things
the same thing with truck drivers and
pilots i read somewhere this weekend oh
we've extended beyond this
and beyond that their normal hours
absolutely untrue
we created a steady drum beat so that it
is a predictable execution
and the right people are in the right
place at the right time to deliver
prepare and deliver the vaccine so we're
working
a myriad of potential things from all
the way to the left
all the way to the right to the center
my responsibility
to deliver safe and effective vaccines
means get ahead of that problem
so we're constantly thinking where do we
need to
where could we possibly be vulnerable
and how do we mitigate it
great general thank you evan thanks for
the question next question please
thank you our next question comes from
elizabeth weiss with usa today
hi thanks so much for taking my question
i wanted to ask about delivery to
rural areas the focus has been at larger
medical centers
in this first week when do you
anticipate it's going to
get out to less populous areas
generally sure mr secretary so i i would
just
i'd reference it back to the states
right where we're enabling
the state's plans in their priorities
and distribution we can deliver it to
any place
that that there's an enrolled vaccine
provider
and that is quite frankly as we did the
map is
throughout all of our states uh
territories
and mega cities so the capacity exists
to do that many states are already
engaging
and working with partners like cvs
walgreens and 17
other key pharmacies to help them expand
uh but at the end of the day we're
enabling uh their ability
or their plan to execute their
priorities
yeah and and elizabeth just on on your
question about rural distribution
again the governors are in charge about
in terms of where
they tell us to ship to one
misconception i get asked about
a lot by the media is the pfizer vaccine
and the
ultra low cold chain around that
uh i just like to we the vice president
i met with
with governor mcmaster and his health
commissioner last week down in south
carolina and
his health commissioner she had a great
line she said you know we're not going
to be storing this vaccine we're going
to be using it
and so we can ship the pfizer vaccine
to rural hospitals rural health centers
etc
it comes packed and dries five days
stable a refreshed five days
on the dry ice there the more complexity
actually with pfizer is
that it comes in 975 doses per package
right now
whereas the madeira will be more
flexible smaller package size and of
course
also regular freezer for for storage for
storage capabilities but
uh there's nothing in the nature of the
pfizer vaccine or distribution that
prevents use in rural
just want to make sure you use all those
doses within the relevant
time frame so thank you how about the
next question
operator next question please
i think your next question comes from
john cohen with science magazine
thank you for taking my question in
keeping with the secretary azar's
commitment for radical transparency
could you please post the dashboard as
real time supply
and delivery information can you reveal
the exact ingredients
secretary said work he provided to
pfizer
can you give us an ex amount invested
specifically in vaccines by warp
so you you broke up a bit we certainly
are releasing the
information about our contractual
commitments as much as we are able to
consistent with the procurement
integrity act there are obviously some
elements of it that
are commercial confidential that we just
legally aren't able to but
we've tried to post our contracts and
other financial commitments fully
and we are also going to be working to
provide a dashboard and information
to be able to ensure that you and the
american public are able
to see the progress on vaccination as we
go i know general if you've got any
update on
on what that will look like so we're we
created the system there is no
system in america that existed until we
came together to bring in
all the authoritative data authoritative
data across the country
into one system so now we do have the
system and we can see ourselves
uh as we are executing the beginning
here we are really just making sure that
everything
tracks so there's a lot of double phone
calls to make sure this says this
and it's very good and then after that
then i see
based on guidance we'll we'll distribute
it accordingly
great thank you general uh we have the
next question please
thank you our next question comes from
carl o'donnell with reuters news
hi this is hi this is carl so uh i was
curious just if you can elaborate a
little bit
on um the the facilities from which
these
these doses are going to be shipped you
know not not just this first tranche but
maybe the uh
you know first uh 25 million or so that
we've been you know hearing about from
pfizers is just going to be the
u.s facilities and is belgium or is
belgium
also going to play a role in providing
supplies
general are you comfortable talking
about that yes so
uh the primary doses for pfizer come out
of
kalamazoo and that
is where they will produce and
distribute it accordingly
we did get some initial doses from
belgium
to help us get going to meet the
requirement
as we've made with pfizer
really is approved accordingly by the
fda
that's only the way we're allowed to
distribute it
but most the remaining vaccines i see
coming from inside of the united states
as we go forward same thing with maduro
and a vaccine when that eventually rolls
and will distribute it from inside the
united states
thanks next question please
your next question comes from lisa
krieger with mercury news
uh yes thank you for taking my call so
it's great that the
east coast immunizations are starting
this morning
can you tell us if the west coast
shipments have gone out when they're
arriving and you know san francisco
sacramento and la
with the statuses on vaccines headed out
here
so they're all every all um
all deliveries will be made today uh i
was told no later than
1400 hours local time right as we're
working through the time zones
uh and distributing accordingly so
i suspect somewhere in the next four
the six hours that it'll be out in the
west coast locations
uh if not already there thank you
great thank you next question please
thank you our next question comes from
meg tyrell what's cnbc
so um i'm wondering if you guys can walk
us through kind of what to expect from
moderna if it gets emergency use
authorization
around the same time what are the
differences
between how the moderna vaccine gets
shipped as it is part of
operation warp speed versus how we've
seen the flys or vaccine get shipped
and could you also talk a little bit
about why there are so many more doses
of modernism now
and they're going to so many more
locations
yeah so so just uh in terms of modern a
timeline
as dr slouwy spoke about meg
[Music]
the advisory committee is on thursday
and assuming that everything remains on
track
we would hope and anticipate fda action
comparable to what we've seen
this last week with pfizer no guarantees
but we would certainly hope the
comparable timeline the biggest
difference which general purna can go
into is
pfizer and madonna are both part of
operation warp speed pfizer chose
however because the ultra cold chain
storage
to ship directly out of their warehouse
facilities
uh using fedex and ups to the sites that
the governors have asked us to have
shipped to
whereas moderna is using mckesson the
wholesale distributor
so they will deploy from the modern
manufacturing into the mc
they will deploy uh through mckesson
also using
the the the logistics companies like
fedex to get the product out there
uh but generally you want to give a
little more detail oh mr secretary
you got it exactly right pfizer just as
you said
to lessen uh the transition with the
ultra cold
went right from their locations to ups
fedex
and then final delivery moderna
chose uh and we supported uh
they're going to use mckesson as their
uh
integrator so they'll take the fill
finished product
uh they'll package it in accordance with
addresses
and quantities and they'll attach
the ancillary kits and it'll be finally
distributed down
again it was just a logistical
decision to ensure just a greater
transition as we went through so really
no big secret there
uh fedex and ups are the key integrators
of the final delivery
down to the final location uh reference
uh the cadence you know let's just you
know
for this conversation assume we might be
on some type of
similar timeline uh our goal would be
for the moderna product to be available
this time uh next week across the united
states so monday tuesday wednesday
a drum beat a vaccine of the initial
push
being sent to all states across the
country
reference the quantities the difference
in quantities
is about what was available when i
we were doing planning to ensure initial
delivery so
as early as
i'm going to get my dates wrong but as
early as
15 november i i had to snap the chore i
snapped the chalk line on what was
available for pfizer
so that states could do planning to the
number as we were sending out the first
doses
we wanted them to have as much time to
do planning
and realize where they wanted it to go
first
and so i snapped the chalk line on what
was available at the time
which was you know over three weeks ago
and that's what went out well
i didn't have to snap the chalk line for
modern until a week or ten days later
as we saw where they were in the process
so they
naturally accumulated more vaccine
available
for the time of final distribution which
allowed me to almost
double the availability from modern
of moderna over pfizer the key is is
that we
we catch up in our following cadence and
allocations
there there is no exact number it's the
number that's available
and uh that's what's allocated you know
uh so that we can assure a flow of
vaccines going out
consistently uh to the states thank you
next question please thank you our next
question comes from
candice choi with ap
i am general purna can you explain what
the dashboard you reference will be
showing
is that going to be distribution is it
going to be uptake and is it going to be
broken down by region and then also you
reference the
581 shipments from thursday through the
weekend
are those part of the first round of 2.9
million doses
or are the 2.9 million doses all being
delivered through wednesday
so the latter question first it's it's
part it's the remaining part of that
right so we we states are ordering to
their
priorities and and where they want it
first and as they did their initial
planning
they wanted it in very certain places uh
uh
up front to do certain things then they
quickly as their plans
you know uh matured wrong
wrong choice of words um as they enacted
their plans
right then they uh immediately went in
and ordered more to follow on
so we got the initial push and now we're
in continuous effort from there
this is what we want so that vaccines go
to the right place at the right time
uh and can be executed uh the first part
dashboards you know i know it's
maybe sound complicated but we do this
in army
tactical operations centers all over the
world we do it
in every time we're on the battlefield
to when we're actually training
it is about seeing yourself um
and understanding uh what is happening
so that you can
identify and get ahead of problems and
make sure that the plan is working
accordingly so you know we're looking at
everything from
uh the dashboards are the work we've
we've been tracking trials
you know you heard dr salawi talk about
how many people are participating in
trial
we're tracking locations where trials
are and what the enrollment is
and what the type of enrollment then
we're tracking manufacturing
we know all 25 facilities we know where
how much work has been done how much
people is there what their supply
requirements are
what their equipment uses what is the
rate of execution
so that we can track and see all of that
then the last dashboard is the final
distribution
it's our ability to know what what's
available
where is it available what is actually
moving
from point a to point b to point c
and when does it arrive at its final
location
and then yes we can track uptake of
vaccine
not by individual but by quantity of
what
has been administered daily weekly
monthly accordingly we want to do this
so that we can ensure the right flow of
vaccine at the right time to the right
places
in support of the states again reminder
this dashboard has never existed
in our lifetime to do this type of
national view
to really mission command
execution from development
trials to manufacturing and now final
distribution
great thank you next question please
thank you our next question comes from
tom hollow with washington times
hi uh thanks for doing the call i know
it's early but have you had any problems
yet that would
require you to tap into that reserve of
500 000 doses
and also do you have a rough estimate of
how many people might get vaccinated
nationwide today
thanks so absolutely no situations
that's required me to tap into
um the safety stock um and so
you know we manage that you know hourly
daily weekly
accordingly i i i don't not unders i
don't know what the uptake would be
mr secretary we'll have
2.9 million doses this week but that's
really going to be a matter of the
progress of the different
uh sites for administration and how
quickly they're able to administer
vaccines so it would be impossible to
project any any particular number for
this week or even today
next question please next question comes
from alicia alt with medscape medical
news
yes thank you for taking my uh question
my
question follows up on the last one a
little bit i'm wondering uh general
perna if you can tell us
if there are any plans to hold back any
of the moderna vaccine
yes there is i mean it's the same it's
the same
uh situation it's two different vaccines
you know i can't we're not going to
enter of course
like that's a decision the two vaccines
have to be treated separately
so first and second dose pfizer you know
to
an individual first and second dose uh
to
uh for moderna uh and our goal is to
make sure that
all vaccine uh is available for both
first and second doses
uh and then the safety stock as i
alluded to would be to mitigate
a situation that could potentially occur
um
you know whether it be weather uh
accidents
uh et cetera so uh yes the answer is we
are
not asked but i'm gonna share share this
is about making sure we're prepared
to mitigate situations as
our process matures both in
manufacturing and in distribution
uh as i've said before the the safety
stock will go down
significantly our goal the guidance i've
been giving
is vaccines sitting on a shelf is not
effective
right we have we have back two vaccines
that are highly efficient the efficacy
is high
uh and we want to get it into the
american people we're just taking
prudent steps
to ensure that the american people have
access to the vaccine
first and second dose and that we remain
capable of ensuring everybody across the
united states gets fair
and equitable distribution confidence
will grow
every day and allow us to reduce
the safety stock accordingly and uh and
i wanted to also
explain something that's come up in some
media questions
around the holdback of vaccines and the
approach given that this
this is a two dose regimen on both the
pfizer and the moderna vaccine so
as the general has explained for both
pfizer and moderna certainly in these
early
weeks of distribution he's taking a bit
of safety stock off the top as he
mentioned the half a million on pfizer
half of that safety stock there just
just
as a just for contingencies unknown
and then distributing out to the states
where the states have asked us to send
half of the remaining doses so that
that's where you get to the 2.9 million
doses of fish are being distributed
this week one of the questions that's
come up is well should you be
distributing even more of that vaccine
to get first dose vaccinations in people
well
we've actually modeled this out this out
quite carefully week by week based on
the expected
release of additional production from
both pfizer
and moderna here's the issue
we need to make sure that if we
vaccinate someone a first time
that we expect there to be a vaccine for
the booster
on the 21st day or the 28th day
either from a held back supply at the
federal level
or from ongoing new production from the
manufacturer that would credibly
be releasable and available for that
person on that date
the clinical trial studies are for the
the first
dose plus the booster the data shows
that's what's needed that's what we have
to be able to support
so if we increase too much the number of
first vaccinations in december you not
only have to be able to provide the
booster in january
but you have to be able to continue
first dose vaccinations of ongoing
populations so
you're managing a flow of first and
second dose vaccinations
as well as a flow coming from
manufacturers
which is the generals talked about we're
manufacturing protein biologics here
and so there you want to make sure
especially in the early weeks of
production
that you build enough safety into it
because what you want to make sure you
get to a point where there is a rhythm
and predictability
on the quality of manufacturing and lots
that are coming off
so that's what we've managed to we are
pushing to the maximum
the number of people to get vaccinated
obviously that's our priority getting as
many people vaccinated as possible
but we do have to be able to ensure
there's a second dose available either
from
from what we've held back or from
realistically expected ongoing
production so that that's come up i
wanted to give that clarification
um if we could have one last question
please
thank you our last question comes from
sharon with new york times
thank you for taking my question uh
general perna indicated on saturday that
20 million doses would be distributed by
the end of the year
on sunday dr slowly gave a lower number
of 14 million
which is the right number and if it went
down can you please explain why
i explained that 20 million
people will be immunized i always said
that
in the month of december before the end
of the year
i'm not sure about the 14 million maybe
the 14 million is actually
the the order of magnitude of the number
of doses coming
out of pfizer or moderna but between the
two
there will be enough vaccine doses to
immunize 20 million people
in the month of december and give them a
second dose in the month
of january and immunize an additional
30 million people in the month of
january yeah just so just to be clear
with all three of us sitting here
uh by the end of december we believe
there will be enough vaccine distributed
to get a first dose vaccination for 20
million people
then as dr slawy just said by the end of
january to add
another 30 million first dose
vaccinations
and then by the end of february
we actually believe we could have a
hundred million
vaccine shots in arms that will have
been
that will have been done between first
dose and
booster shot vaccinations of individuals
and as dr slawy has said
uh by the end of that's by the end of
the first quarter by the end of march
a hundred million actual individuals who
have had at least a first dose
vaccination
correct dr yes actually we
we plan to have 200 million doses of
vaccine
by the end of the first quarter so by
the end of march
which would be enough to have immunized
100 million people
and depending on the performance of the
janssen's vaccine and the isoscele
vaccine phase 3 programs
and emergency use authorization we
expect
a significant number of doses
potentially from the jansens vaccine
in february already and even more in
march
and of course as a single dose regimen
those are vaccination equals
person vaccinated at that point so uh
yeah so that's why we are so confident
in the flow
uh and the vaccine schedules that we've
talked about but i think very
consistent in what we've tried to
present to you all so we will continue
to do these briefings
i'm going to be going shortly to gw
hospital where i'm going to get to see
several of the first individuals getting
vaccinated are heroic
frontline healthcare workers here i
want to get to see them getting
vaccinated and see the process underway
a very comprehensive program that gw
hospital set up to
organize and allocate vaccine among
their healthcare their frontline
healthcare workers
so we'll be doing a lot of that this
week as our leaders try to
make sure that the american public see
our complete confidence in the process
used to to get to these vaccines to have
a credible
scientific determination by the fda and
encourage all those who are designated
by their
state's governors to uh to go ahead and
get vaccinated please so thank you very
much and
caitlin if you don't close us thank you
all very much please send in
any follow-up questions to our press
office at media hhs.gov
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you